what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be talking about
why i think getting a low maintenance
girlfriend or wife is actually really
important for the average guy um
obviously there's exceptions to every
rule and a millionaire probably won't
have a problem with a high maintenance
girlfriend
um but this is just my two cents before
i start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos okay so
i just put in
three things so
hair
how much
does it cost
to
dye your hair
um
oh my gosh
i gotta
i do microsoft
paste okay
um hair coloring and highlights cost
between
50 and 70 dollars um a hundred
and 150 so let's let's say
because it says low end 50 to 70
100 to 150 so let's say
a hundred dollars
then
we're gonna get nails so
how much
does it cost to get a mani pedi
with acrylics
um
um okay okay a mani pedi on average will
be approximately 35 to 60.
um
that actually seems low to me to be
honest but let's let's just go with 60
bucks
so that would be every two weeks so in a
month it'd be like 120.
um
now close so
google
how much does the average
woman pay
for clothes
in a month let's say in a month
so
35
let's say 40 bucks per month
just go with that
oh and that's pounds so
35 pounds
uh let's just i'm gonna guess 60 roughly
okay
um
so this is going to be monthly cost just
so you can see so
nails you have to do every two weeks so
i did 60 times two hair
um
i would say once every three months
maybe for a hair dye
let's let's see how
often do you need to dye
your hair
every oh six to eight weeks so okay
let's just say two months then
so
it's a hundred bucks let's say 50
per month equals
so that's 230 a month for those things
and i'm gonna make these all dollars
okay
so
two hundred thirty dollars
times twelve
is two thousand
seven hundred sixty dollars per year
so
if you're married to a girl for five
years
that is about 14 000 now
honestly i'm looking at these numbers
and i feel like these are low like if i
had to guess
like the last time i got my hair cut it
was like eight months ago and it was
over a hundred dollars
i would guess would be more so like
let's say she's on the higher end
100 let's say she spends 150 on nails a
month
and let's say she spends a hundred
dollars
on
and then
i feel like did the switch
okay equals
oh so that's going to be equals 350.
yeah so then it becomes 21 000
every five years
i don't know about you but to a guy
making let's say 60 000 a year that's a
lot of money
so
this is why i really would recommend
like to my brothers and to any guy i
know to really look at girls that are
low maintenance um versus high
maintenance because
her bills are going to become your bills
at some point
and i don't think guys understand how
much it actually costs to maintain a lot
of the things that look good i'm not
even gonna lie they look good
they're nice but like
where do you want to spend your money
so find a girl that has the same values
as you if you like to spend money so be
it personally i'm cheap but let me know
in the comments if you guys agree or you
disagree and don't forget to subscribe